all right so i just finished my round
four game
and it was a really long fight and i'm
kind of hungry now so
as usual i'm gonna try and keep this
brief
but it was also just a really
interesting game um i'll probably have a
lot a lot to talk about a lot of lines
to discuss
so i was playing a player by the name of
shublada
who's actually from the us but i haven't
heard his uh his name before
and he's one of three players from the
us playing this tournament the other two
being myself and ray robson
so uh yeah he's younger player maybe 14
or 15 years old
and uh he's gained hundreds of elo
within the last year or two
so i knew it was not going to be an easy
game
and
i decided to go for a taimanov sicilian
which is one of my main
openings as black
i've been playing a lot of different
sicilians these days between uh
accelerated dragon
uh the dragondorff
uh the previous round round two i played
the classical sicilian had a fun opening
there
um but here i played uh playtime on of
which is a line i've been playing for
many many years
uh probably since i was rated around
like 2100 and 2200
and
i decided to play this because i saw he
had um he had one game in the slime
queen f3 at least one game i could find
and this is a line that has been really
trendy
in recent years among like top level
grand masters and it's an attempt to
refute the timon of completely and i
actually stopped playing the taimanov
for a while partly because of this line
the point of queen f3 is to
get a pretty double-edged position after
queenside castle eventually queen g3
there are some lines actually where the
queens got traded and it's um a nice
positional play for white especially if
uh h pawn takes and the h file opens so
um
i did a lot of preparation before the
game and uh i was very much ready to
meet queen f3 with knight to f6
and next few moves follow prep 95 queen
g3 b5
and f4 so it's already getting pretty
sharp
knight's attacked knight g4
this is still prep
and uh here there's a few moves for
white uh the main move being bishop g1
which is what he played
um there's actually a small trap here is
that if white plays e5 too early
then i don't actually have to move the
knight i can take on e3 and after queen
e3 there's b4
and this is already considered to be
better for black
i see there's a
bunch of games on each s but if we see
master's database black scores really
well here
uh i think i'll go ahead and hide
notation just to avoid any potential
spoilers
but
yeah bishop g1 was played
i play h5 i should note that after
bishop b1 white is threatening e5
removing my knight from differing the
other knight so h5 adds extra support
he plays e5 anyway and i use a similar
idea to counter-attack the nylon c3
and this is a very important move
because if i don't have b4 then what
what am i doing with this knight on f6
so here white has an option um he played
the move that i was expecting knight a4
i think this is also possible but i
maybe black is already doing well here
just because uh
the queen side's opening up and uh black
king is actually very safe
so he plays knight a4
and i centralize my knight
and here he plays bishop d3
so
bishop d3 was the first move
slightly out of my preparation
uh the main line i had prepared like an
hour before the game was h3 knight h6
and f5
um assuming i'm remembering this
correctly and this is a really really
crazy line which i don't think i'll have
too much time
to delve into the details but
i was prepared maybe five or ten moves
more beyond this
i'm not sure if i would have remembered
my preparation during the game
but we didn't go quite into this
and before the game i also looked at
bishop d3 in this position
after which g6 can be played so
when he played bishop d3 in the game uh
i'd pretty quickly play g6
um just very similar idea uh and this is
a useful move because it discourages
pawn f5 and it secures f5 square for the
potential night maneuver
but on top of this i realized um
during the game
there's cars honking outside the window
i don't know if people can hear that
but uh what was i saying
oh yeah i realized during the game that
there's actually a cool trick here
is if white plays h3 here
i don't actually have to play knight h6
i can play bishop h6
threatening to take on f4
but also pinning the f pawn so i'm
threatening to take on e5
and uh i think this is already like very
very good for black
so after i play g6 he took
kind of the first long think of the game
yeah he spent almost 20 minutes we can
see by the time stamps
to play king b1
and um i think this is the best move now
i'm not going to analyze with engine
just yet and i i haven't analyzed with
engine at all i just got back from or
just finished the game like 20 minutes
ago so i'll save engine analysis for
later
but uh yeah king b1 just getting off
this diagonal and now if i play
bishop h6 he can probably just play a
move to defend the pawn
so i decided to develop bishop b7
he kicks the knight i move back and
bishop e4
rook c8 so natural improving moves
and at queen f3 creating the battery
also uh enabling the g pawn to move in
certain cases white would like to play
g4
so i play knight to f5
and there's a tricky line here i set up
a small trap that if white does play g4
i can take take trade rooks and then
play knight g3 with a pretty nasty fork
and after queen moves somewhere i take
take and knight c3 with a discovered
quadruple fork and this would be really
nice
so of course he didn't go into that
but uh it's nice to fantasize about the
funny lines
um instead he plays bishop f2 which is a
much more solid move connecting the
rooks also restricting my knight so um
yeah here the the position is very very
tense a lot of tension between the
knights between the bishops on the
diagonal i have the battery on the c
file but the pawns defended by knight
and bishop
this knight's a bit loose so there are a
lot of things going on here and uh
yeah it was it was a difficult position
to kind of process what exactly is going
on
um but i decided to play queen a5 here
after a very long thing
uh spent 21 minutes on this move
and there were so many like just crazy
lines
i was calculating
um which i'm super curious to check with
the engine
but i'm gonna
resist for for another few moments
um the point of point a5 is simply to
attack the knight on a4
and the first line i calculated was b3
but i think this is losing for white
after knight c3
and uh of course i'm hitting the king
and hitting the bishop so after takes
takes
even though my bishop would be hanging
uh i have this mating idea so
uh if we got to this position i don't
think white has a good defense
just because
yeah how does white stop the plan of
queen a3 queen b2
and if bishop e3 is played
then i can just take it
and then still play this and queen's c1
doesn't work because i can take take and
then win the bishop in the end
so
uh he didn't play b3
um
and he played the move i actually wasn't
expecting when i played queen a5 i sent
spent most of my time calculating
a really crazy knight b6
which at first looks impossible because
knight is attacked twice
but if i take with the knight then
bishop takes b7
and if i take with the queen i'm
aligning with a bishop on f2 and white
can take here
so
um
so yeah if knight b6 were played i was
actually thinking about playing
a really insane move rook c3 oops not
mouse slip but rook c3
um
yeah just a crazy line hitting the queen
leaving the rook attacked but if takes i
would take and then when the bishop and
the knight will hang eventually i might
also be just having a mating attack
so um
yeah if rook c3 i was looking at rook to
d3
and
i spent so much time on queen a5 because
i couldn't quite
come to a definite conclusion about this
line like i was calculating further here
it's actually looking at a funny line
takes takes in b3
i don't think this works but it would be
really funny because
so much stuff is happening
um
so i'll probably analyze this later with
the engine i'll also leave a link to the
game in the video description in case
people want to analyze all the funny
lines on their own
but let's get back to the game because
he um he went for a completely different
direction he took on f5 which i
i kind of dismissed when i played queen
a5 because after he takes back i'm
hitting the bishop and hitting the
knight
and it turns out that white has to
sacrifice material here
after takes takes
uh the only way to keep the game
somewhat close is to take on d5 with the
rook
so i completely missed this idea when i
played queen a5
but
i think overall i was happy to see this
because we get to an end game after
takes
takes takes i'm up the exchange
and um white does win back the pawn
after knight p6 rook c6 knight takes e5
but
once i had time to evaluate the position
i was pretty sure that
black is really the only one playing for
a win
even though it's imbalanced and
yeah white has knight in pawn for rook
but
there's a lot of things going in black's
favor given i have the half open g file
half upon c file
even though my pawns look a bit weak
they're actually hard for white to
exploit because i have a five coming if
ever knight e3 i have bishop c5 which is
a very useful resource
and um
yeah there's not too many like potential
forks around the king
especially after my next bishop e7
um just kind of restricting any knight
f6 move and potentially wanting to go to
d8 to completely restrict the knight
so
i was feeling pretty good at this point
still had some time advantage
uh but of course it's very much a fight
he plays h4
which i think is a reasonable move
preventing me from playing h4
i play rook g8 hitting the g pawn g3
and now rook to g6
so decided not to castle this game but
rather to rook lift
and uh figured this was the only logical
way to activate the rook
and now there's some ideas of maybe rook
c4 and rook c6 to double up
um and then
also another idea with rook to g6 is to
maybe play
f6 or d6 eventually
try and disturb
white's nice pawn on e5
and eventually that is what happened
after rook d1 a5 rook e1
rookie 6 b3 i finally get in this move
pawn f6
and it looks a little bit weird because
i put my rook
uh
on a square where it doesn't have any
moves and if somehow the knight could
attack it the rook would be trapped but
there's no good way for the knight to
attack it
these moves just
are not possible
so um so yeah after f6 uh my opponent
played bishop d4
and
at first i thought i was in very good
shape but the more i i thought about the
position the more i realized
it's still very very tricky
because white has enough defenders on e5
and the move i initially wanted to play
here was d6
which just leads to a
very funny setup with the rooks and
pawns aligned on the sixth rank
the point of course is to attack the
pawn multiple times and exploit the fact
the pawn is pinned
but i didn't end up going for this move
because i wasn't sure how to evaluate
bishop b6
threatening knight c7
and
i was calculating some funny lines here
but i couldn't quite
make them work
like i wanted to go for this takes give
back the exchange and then after takes
takes
uh there's an idea to trap the bishop
after takes and then rook a6
but i wasn't sure about this because
white has rook d1
and if i play like king c8 there's rook
to d5
um and wherever the king moves the
bishop is going to have the square the
king c6 with bishop d8
and if yeah king here there's bishop b7
so
it's possible d6 was a good move but uh
i decided to go for a different approach
and i took on e5
and played bishop c5
and it took me a while to even consider
this but
i think it's just a simpler option
going for
some simplification
he plays bishop b2 and now i have the
move bishop f2
and this leads to a bunch of trades of
pawns because i am guaranteed to win the
g pawn the white wins my f pawn
and then the h pawns come off the board
and
because i'm playing for a win
it is a little bit risky trading a lot
of pawns because if white can just keep
trading pawns and
it just becomes much more difficult to
win
uh when you're up the exchange so i did
want to keep
at least a few pawns on the board
and i was fortunate here to have the
mover h6
uh to basically defend the
uh the bishop through x-ray vision and
offering the trader rooks
and i here i was expecting my opponent
to go for the rook train
after which
i'm not sure how
easy this would be to win like it's
probably closer to a draw than than a
win for black uh because there's
eventual a3 or c3 and more pawns are
being traded
but my opponent played rook f5 and i
think this is a practical mistake
because
i'm able to keep both rooks on the board
and the rooks are able to work together
very nicely
especially to team up against the c pawn
as we'll see
so um i took a think here originally i
wanted to play bishop e1
uh to threaten this or this
but then white has rook f1 i was
calculating some bishops e3
but then i considered a different move
bishop to d8 and once i saw this i
realized this is actually a really nice
word for the bishop holds together the a
pawn restricts the knight and plans the
same
rook h1 or rook h2
and white can only stop one move so my
opponent play rook f1 i get my rook to
the second rank
and uh
as we see by the time situation we uh
we're both getting low on time but my
opponent's a bit lower in time
he plays knight to e3 defending c2
and here i realized that it's still not
so simple because the move i want to
play is bishop g5 but then he has knight
c4
and it just cuts off my rook from
attacking the pawn and the knight's
really solid here
so i
found a tricky move to play pawn a4
trying to deflect the pawn
away from covering c4
and
i was expecting my opponent to play this
anyway after which i would play a3 and
um
yeah maybe there's still chances to win
this
but to my surprise my opponent took the
pawn
and then this just allowed um
non-stop initiative
for for me after bishop g5 the knight no
longer has the c4 square has to move and
then i win the c2 pawn hitting the
bishop
and here we see white's position
crumbling after rook a2
i win the a4 pawn
and yeah it's very very close to mate
like all i need to do is get my rook to
the b file but i can't play rook b4 just
yet so i start with rook 2 a5 hitting
the knight threatening rook to b5
um he plays knight c7
i play king d8
and then he plays bishop to c3
so as we see white's pieces are in a bit
of disarray
um knights hanging kings of target
rooks not being too useful here and i'm
still cutting the king off as well
so here i play rook 2 c5
now both minor pieces are hanging and he
had one last trick here played bishop to
b4
and uh i have to be sure not to
to cash in too quickly because if i take
the knight
uh i would be up a rook in this position
but i would also be getting mated in one
move
so i saw that and instead play rook
back to c2
and here i'm not getting mated because
of rook f8 which is what he played i
just take the knight
and uh it's me who's threatening the the
force mate with eventual rook b2 rook a2
and then the other rook to b2
uh we played on a few more moves bishop
g6
um i have to be careful not to play king
c6 because that would lead to a draw
but
king b7
rook c3 and he resigned in this position
so
yeah a very very hard fought game um a
lot of different stages in this game
between just opening preparation
the really tense middle game
the possibility of a lot of crazy
tactics
and then the end game struggle as well
so i'm i feel relieved to
come away with a win i think this this
game could have easily been a draw if
maybe my opponent
played a bit more precisely in the end
game
but
yeah can't complain i am currently two
out of four
uh beating the low rated players who
i've played and losing to a couple very
strong grand masters
so tomorrow is round five
uh it will start at 5 pm abu dhabi time
if you want to watch live i will leave a
link to the broadcast in the video
description
and yeah thanks again if you made this
far
let me know in the comments let me know
if you have any questions and i'll see
you guys in the next video